i said so geez what do you want to work
on next what do you want to work on i
want an unlimited shopping spree
now what am i going to say to her no hey
it's evan carmichael and like dr joe
dispenza says
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so let's help you
create the state of being that you want
with dr joe dispenza and my take on his
top 10 rules for success
need motivation watch your top 10 with
believe nation
okay let's kick it off with rule number
one focus on your goals if you're alive
in this world and you haven't been
experiencing the quickening i mean i
mean
you know i said to uh someone the other
day
the day where you end your day and feel
complete because you finished all your
work you'll never have that you know
there's always more emails and more
things to check right so the demand has
has
has pressed us into this crazy realm of
of
of of um
multitasking
and i think that
you start shifting where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
so if you're shifting your attention all
over the board your energy is scattered
yeah so then when you start
disconnecting from everybody your boss
your co-worker you know the news
your cell phone your computer and you
start going this way i think it's
into the present moment then of where
you place your attention is where you
place your energy and you're truly in
the present moment you've got a lot of
energy to execute you've got to let that
energy to use and you want to be able to
do that eyes open the more scattered
your energy the less you have to focus
on pushing one thing forward that's why
people's dreams don't happen because
they're scattered
there's no look look if you keep putting
your attention on some future experience
that you are imagining with your mind
your body is going to follow your mind
right there because that's where your
energy is but if you're putting your
attention on everything known in your
life the shower the coffee maker you
know
the toilet and your body's following
your mind every day to the known but we
want your body to follow your mind to
the unknown right enough people get to
doing that
and you could do better in creating
things in your life that we see this
wealthy people in our work that have
focused on wealth some of them living in
the back seat of their car some of them
bankrupt that now have multi-million
dollar companies what do you think they
want to do with that money
they want to give it away yeah give it
back let me tell you why not because of
any other reason is that they now know
that they create more right well why why
if you're abundant why abundance to me
has changed abundance means i have more
than i need like way more than i need so
if i have way more than i need and i
know how to create it
then take it i'll create more of it so
now you're no longer holding on in
scarcity
you're making a difference so wealthy
people that have created a lot of wealth
in this work they want to give back they
want to make a difference and i think
that that's how we're innately wired i
think we're all innately wired to care
for one another to make a difference in
the living organism our living organism
our community we heal one another that's
what we do right we inform one another
we encourage one another we support one
another
we shine for one another not to outshine
another person to shine to show them if
they can shine and that's that to me is
super healthy so then i'm i'm applauding
your success because i want you to
succeed because you're telling me that
if you can do it i can do it so so
there's no longer any separation i think
that's hopeful for the world then you
start celebrating diversity then you're
like wow you're way different than me i
want to i want to study you because i
want to bring that into who i'm becoming
yeah you create a strong community that
way rule number two go all in what are
the things that
disturb or
disconnect our awakening and connection
to the divine a lot of times when people
they hit that point they try to
reproduce it the same way as we talked
about and you can't yeah you can't do it
the same way because that's redundancy
but also many times uh we have the
experience and we start to try
and because trying is matter trying to
change matter and and so we're forcing
we're controlling we're predicting and
and then the uh and when we do that then
of course we're in separation and we're
waiting for the event to happen to feel
the emotion right and
i've done that
long enough and it's actually have to
lay down
the very thing we used our whole life to
get we want for something greater to
occur and it takes practice of surrender
right
so
that's one element i also think that our
responses emotionally
like uh
uh
let's just say that a person gets
connected to the future they get
connected to the energy of their future
they feel it it's really great and then
they start their day and then two hours
later they're they're feeling something
else because some person or some
circumstance altered their state well
they just disconnected from the energy
of the future and now they're back to
the energy of the past don't expect
anything to change in your life because
then work that way
so then
then when they get back to that old self
again then they say what's wrong with me
i failed they didn't do it right no
that's all the program you show up again
and you go after it again
so familiar feelings
cause us
to no longer see through the lens of the
future we're seeing through the lens of
the past and
and we color reality that way so
um
i think i think familiar emotions uh get
in the way as well and then of course
there's always belief
and a belief is just a thought you keep
thinking over and over again until you
hardwire it in your brain and all
beliefs are based on past experience so
a person has an experience the stronger
the emotion they have from that
circumstance the more they pay attention
to the cause and the brain freezes a
frame takes a snapshot and that's called
the memory
the moment they draw a conclusion about
that experience they'll think
neurologically within those circuits and
they'll feel chemically within the
boundaries of the motion thinking and
feeling thinking and feeling belief
becomes an unconscious or subconscious
state of being they don't most people
don't even know they have beliefs about
things about god about relationships
about money because it's it's not a
conscious thing it's a subconscious
thing yeah so in order to change a
belief or a perception
about yourself and your life
you got to go all in
it's not like you go 50 in you got to go
all in you got to make a decision
with such firm intention
that the amplitude of that decision
carries a level of energy
that causes the body to respond to the
mind that the choice that you make
becomes a moment in time you'll never
forget and you would say
i remember the moment
i made up my mind to change and the
stronger the emotion you feel the more
you'll pay attention to the decision and
that's a huge stone you drop in the
quantum field big splash big waves rule
number three make new connections your
brain is organized to reflect everything
you know in your life
your brain
is a record of the past
it's an artifact
of all the things you've learned and
experienced to this moment
so if you wake up every morning
and get out of bed on the same side
shut the alarm clock off with the same
finger shuffle into the bathroom and use
the toilet like you always do
go and get a cup of coffee and drink
coffee out of your favorite mug
then get in the shower and wash yourself
off in the same routine way
drive to work
get to work see the same people
that push the same emotional buttons
do the same things that you've memorized
and do so well then hurry up and go home
and hurry up and check your emails
and hurry up and check your facebook and
then watch your favorite television show
then hurry up and go to bed
here's my question
did your brain change at all that day
we could say that you were thinking the
same thoughts performing the same
unconscious actions
living by the same emotions but secretly
expecting your life to change
so there's a principle in neuroscience
and the principle says
nerve cells that fire together
wire together
so if you're thinking the same thoughts
making the same choices
demonstrating the same behaviors
reproducing the same experiences that
stamp the same networks of neurons into
the same patterns
and then produce the same emotions
you're going to hardwire your brain
into a very finite signature
because as you fire and wire the same
circuits in the same way
those circuits begin to become more
connected
and by the time you're 35 years old this
is science now
we become a set of memorized behaviors
unconscious habits
automatic emotional reactions beliefs
and perceptions and even attitudes that
function just like a computer program
and if you do something over and over
and over again
the repetition of those actions over
time conditions your body to know how to
do it well better than your mind
and a habit is when your body knows
better than your mind
where you've done something so many
times that the body now knows how to do
it better than the brain
and so 95 percent of most people's
behaviors
attitudes thoughts beliefs
emotional reactions are subconscious
programs
so why is that important
because you're here this week
to learn new information
and every time you learn something new
you make new connections in your brain
that's what learning is
learning is forging new synaptic
connections
physical evidence
as a result of your interaction in the
environment
and the footprints of consciousness is
called learning making new connections
and the nobel prize laureate candel in
the year 2000
found that when people learned one bit
of information
they doubled the number of connections
in their brain
from thirteen hundred connections to
twenty six hundred connections
but if they didn't review that
information
if they couldn't repeat it
if they couldn't remember it those
circuits pruned apart in hours or days
so if learning is making new synaptic
connections
then remembering is maintaining and
sustaining those connections rule number
four open your heart your body rejects
viruses all the time of course it has
memorized certain viruses that you've
been exposed to
it's memorized certain bacteria that
you've been exposed to and it's beaten
those viruses not every virus wins in
the body the body has an intelligence
and it's and it has
quite a library of memories in the in
the white blood cells so your body is
fighting viruses and bacteria all the
time there's a constant competition
going on really so our research shows
that four days
of opening your heart
releases immunoglobulin a your body's
primary defense against bacteria and
viruses it's better than the flu shot
it's the body's natural flu shot and
that's the innate intelligence of the
body saying i got this i got a lot of
energy in fact i got a surplus of energy
in fact i'm radiating energy and now too
much around the world
now my outer world is not controlling my
inner world my inner world now is
functioning independent of what's going
on in my outer world and now
you're manifesting your manifesto ah now
you got it now you're in a creative
state because people are coming to you
yes right exactly now you're a magnet
now you have a field right and you have
energy
to heal and our research shows that that
field around your body will actually
expand you you radiate more light and
information cells
are getting new information that that
are causing
light to be exchanged between cells and
information now the body's getting an
upgrade so so that immunoglobulin a in
four days went up 50
so now we now know that if it's going up
50 that then the immune system was
getting a new signal and nitric oxide
then
causes another chemical to activate the
arteries in your heart to swell and now
just like when energy moves into your
sexual organs and it swells blood and
you have energy there the same intensity
it moves into your heart
and now
now the heart is activated and what do
you feel
you feel an incredible amount of love
yeah and you feel you feel you feel
whole and now the more whole you feel
our research shows
then the less separate you feel from the
things you want in your life because
you feel like you already have them you
only want things when you're in lack but
when you feel whole then it feels like
it's already happened and that tends to
be the exact emotion
that causes those synchronicities and
serendipities and coincidences to happen
in our life and you say to a person what
are you doing and they're saying i'm not
doing anything
i'm just i'm loving life i'm being
myself i'm yeah right i'm free i'm free
from the past i'm free from my story of
the past in fact i'm more connected to
the energy of my future
than i am to the energy of my past
also to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video i've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the lessons learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business i'll see you
there rule number five tap into
constructive energy i think that if we
share
the same experiences because we like the
same things
we share the same emotions
and if we share the same experiences we
share the same emotions i can relate to
you so we can exchange ideas and
information yeah and if we share the
same energy energy is information so
many people as an example
they use each other to reaffirm their
their dependency on suffering so i
suffer more than you then you say i you
i suffer you suffer more than me we have
this thing we just complain with each
other well that's the same resonance the
same frequency and there's a match right
uh but goes to the same means if you if
you're if you're
someone who's has a uh accountability
partner that that you exchange ideas
like this with and it's a different
frequency and different energy so
when energy comes together as
constructive something comes out of it
yeah you feel it right it's and you feel
an elevation if there's dissonance then
your your sensing meter is how you feel
about that person many times in your gut
or in your heart or wherever and there's
decon there's a
destructive interference and there's no
energy involved so
i think that's just a practice but
really
the ultimate mastery
is to be able to be in such residence
such coherence
that when you walk in the room that you
raise
everybody's energy and you don't let
your energy drop because of any
circumstance or any condition then that
would be greater than your environment
right and that's that's the model uh
that we use so imagine 1 500 people
in an event
where everybody's getting super coherent
and the interference that's going on in
the room is creating these high
amplitudes and we've measured that in
the room and the energy in the room is
off the chart many times there's i mean
there's energy for healing in there
there's energy for all kinds of things
that can happen so we brought it to life
with our awareness and so
the more elevated the emotion love
gratitude freedom bliss ecstasy the
higher the frequency
so but it turns out you can have a
collective group of people with a lot of
energy and be incoherent and it creates
entropy yeah you could have a smaller
group of people that are highly coherent
and put out a very big signal
so when we see a collective really get
coherent
wow the energy in the room opens up
doors
of possibilities that i would i would
never expect i mean i i don't i don't
know how to explain some of the
phenomenological things that happen
but that's that's everybody's divine
like everybody's everybody's in that
state they're they're in that elevated
state so
i think our i think our truth meter is
really whether we feel it lifted
or we feel like we've been robbed rule
number six have a vision if you are not
defined by some vision
that is bigger than you and you are not
passionate about that vision then you're
left with the old hardware of the past
in your brain and you will be
predictable in your life
so would you agree then
new thoughts
new information should lead to new
choices
new choices should lead to new behaviors
and new behaviors should create new
experiences
and new experiences should produce new
emotions
and those new emotions should drive new
thoughts and that's called evolution
so if your brain is a record of the past
and you don't have a vision of the
future
then you are living in the past
and you will never arrive at that new
future rule number seven watch your
thoughts if you have been an experienced
uh if you had experience of trauma say
for example and it's created the feeling
of fear and your fear is that it could
happen again
and you're you don't know this but every
time you think about that future that
possible worst case scenario scenario
and you feel the emotion you're
conditioning your body to become the
mind subconsciously of anxiety
so now
all you need now is some cue in your
outer environment that says it's unsafe
that if there's damage there that you're
you're a victim something's bigger than
you that could have an effect on you
well now that feeling of fear
is going to cause you to think thoughts
equal to it
so the person then
no longer needs the environment
to feel that fear they just have to have
the thought about
that condition now and now they're
literally knocking their brain and body
out of balance by thought alone and the
body's constantly living in emergency
mode and it takes a lot of energy
a lot of resources to live in emergency
mode all the time guess what system
becomes compromised by the immune system
your immune system why because you have
two protection systems you gotta get a
system that protects you from dangers in
your outer world that's that's the gas
pedal that's the sympathetic nervous
system that's a fight-or-flight nervous
system danger threat out there use all
the energy because you gotta you gotta
survive and when you survive you gotta
take care of your body so right so so
now
that system can work really well short
term
it doesn't work really well if you keep
it on all the time because if you're
mobilizing all that energy for some
thread in your outer world there's no
energy in your inner world for growth
and repair there's no energy for
long-term building projects and energy
leaves the brain and it leaves the heart
and it moves into these lower centers
because now you're tapping the body's
resources because there is an emergency
but whether the emergency is real or
imagined
whether your anger is valid or justified
or not
that the you're tapping the body's very
energy to heal by doing this and the
immune system says
well we're part of really the other
nervous system we're the break we're the
clutch
we need the we need to get into
relaxation we need to get back into
balance again and and when we do then
we'll metabolize then we'll we'll
assimilate we'll reproduce we'll
excrete properly
so
so now you got a this kind of battle
between the gas pedal and the brake and
the immune system says hey listen if
there's foreign agents if there's
viruses bacteria molds funguses listen
we don't have a whole lot of energy here
to deal with them because we're fighting
this war out there there's no homeland
security so they shut down
certain receptors in the immune system
they shut down function
of those lymphocytes those white blood
cells that are your inner army of
protection and it takes a lot of energy
to fight a virus in a bacteria but if
there's no energy hey listen it takes
energy to raise the body's temperature
where do you think that comes from
that's part of that branch called the
autonomic nervous system and the
sympathetic the gas pedal is part of it
and the parasympathetic is the clutch is
part of that autonomic nervous system
and it's a check and balance but so you
stay in emergency for an extended period
of time
and now you're exposed to some
antigen or some
external substance some foreign agent
rule number eight believe in yourself
when we become the living example of
truth when we actually embody this
that
there are no limits to what we can do
and i'm hopeful with human beings that
that uh we have this capacity and uh
and of course when we believe in
ourselves uh we believe in possibility
and when we believe in possibilities we
believe in ourselves and i think that is
the ultimate belief rule number nine
break the cycle
feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you can remember experiences better
because you can remember how they feel
and when you're in the midst of an
experience
all of your senses plug you into the
environment
and as you're gathering all of this
vital data from your external world
all that information rushes back to your
brain
and it causes jungles of neurons to
organize themselves into networks
the moment those neurons string into
place the brain makes a chemical and
that chemical is called a feeling or an
emotion
and once you feel that emotion you
create a long-term memory
now reason this with me
if feelings and emotions are the end
product of past experiences
and you are feeling the same way
every single day
doesn't that mean nothing new is
happening in your life
and if those feelings and emotions drive
certain thoughts
and you can't think greater than how you
feel
because you had events in your life that
have branded you emotionally
and you feel sadness or guilt or shame
or unworthiness or insecurity
all of those emotions are created from
past experiences
and when you feel those emotions
and those emotions drive certain
thoughts
and then those thoughts make certain
chemicals for you to feel the same
emotion
and then those emotions drive certain
thoughts
the repetition of that cycle then
conditions the body
to memorize that emotional state better
than the mind
and now your body literally is in the
past
because if you can't think greater than
how you feel then you are thinking in
the past
and so most people then
spend the majority of their life
talking about
why they never arrive at their vision of
the future
because of some past experience
and so if feelings and emotions are the
end product of past experiences you
remember your first kiss
you remember your wedding you remember
the birth of your children you remember
catching a fish off the coast of
manzanillo with your three best friends
because you caught the fish and it was a
new experience and you felt great
and then you went
to the casita and you cooked the
mahi-mahi and you drank sauvignon blanc
and the wind was blowing off the sea and
the sun was setting
and you made a long-term memory
[Music]
but you also have memories that are
connected to trauma and crisis
to disappointments
and those are the memories that people
remember more than anything else
and so if you haven't overcome some
emotion
that keeps you anchored to the past
then you tell a story about the past
and people say
i am this way because of this experience
that happened to me
15 years ago
i am this way because of some event that
happened thirty years ago
and from a biological perspective
it means i haven't been able to change
in the last fifteen or thirty years
and scientific american
a prestigious magazine
says that 50 percent
of what you talk about in your past
isn't even the truth
you make it up
because you don't have the same brain
that you did 15 years ago or 30 years
ago
so then your brain and body are
typically in the past
because thoughts are the language of the
brain
and feelings are the language of the
body
and how you think and how you feel
creates your state of being
so if you think insecure thoughts
in a matter of seconds you are going to
feel insecure
the moment you feel insecure
your brain is monitoring how you're
feeling and you think more insecure
thoughts
which then makes you feel more insecure
and the repetition of that cycle
conditions the body to become the mind
of insecurity
and then the person says
i
am insecure
and whenever you say i am anything you
are commanding your mind and body into a
destiny so then how do people change
they wait for crisis
trauma
disease
diagnosis loss
something has to go wrong in their life
where they feel so uncomfortable that
they finally make up their mind to
change
and why is that
because after the trauma or the crisis
they don't feel like of themselves
and the moment they don't feel like
themselves they could actually observe
themselves
because they're looking at themselves
through the eyes of someone else
but my message is why wait
you can learn and change in a state of
pain and suffering
or you can learn and change in a state
of joy and inspiration and rule number
10 the last one before some very special
bonus clips is stop excusing yourself
memory is creative that in fact fifty
percent of that story you embellish
people make up that story let me tell
you why they make up that story
because they excuse themselves for the
fact that they haven't been able to
change
since that event they'll have to make it
sound worse than it really was to make
it harder to grow and change
so that they can reaffirm their limited
sense of their inability to change so
then that story becomes more and more of
a story it's less of the truth because
you got to work yourself up into a state
there were lions and tigers and they
were right you know they were helicopter
snowstorms and everybody was firing
bullets
worse than you could possibly imagine
and then you got to feel that emotion
right and then you look at this oh yeah
it must have been really bad now that's
that's your identity now that's your
identity
when things are bad you feel bad so
there's dramatic contrast and polarity
and this is the realm of polarity right
so how do you find the middle path well
the heart is the middle path it's the
union of polarity it's the union of
opposites it's it's oneness it's
wholeness and this is where we have to
begin to create from all of this down
here is all humanity this is all our
animal nature we get up in here things
change right
you go from selfish to selfless and
something else happens so
it's really funny too because when
a lot of people come they say i i don't
know i'm having difficulty opening my
heart
i'm you know i'm practicing but i'm not
feeling anything yet and then it comes
time to do our healings on other people
and
the moment you
it was no longer about you all of a
sudden something happened well of course
that's what the heart is about right so
so it comes in ways that we least expect
at times a habit is a redundant set of
automatic unconscious thoughts behaviors
and emotions that's acquired through
repetition
a habit is when you've done something so
many times that the body now knows how
to do it better than the mind
so now the person running through the
same routine every single day is on
autopilot and their body's now dragging
them
into a predictable future based on what
they did in the past and they've lost
their free will
to a set of programs right so now you
have the familiar past and you have the
predictable future those are knowns
so the only place then reasonably where
the unknown exists is the sweet spot of
the generous present moment that is when
the body and mind are free from those
conditions so along with those emotions
that influence the same thoughts
people start becoming more judgmental
they start becoming more impatient they
start becoming more entitled
they start getting more afraid more
anxious more depressed and now the body
is literally being depleted
of energy because it's believing that
it's living in an emergency situation
and in emergency you tap all the body's
resources for some threat whether it's
real or imagined
and so then when you're releasing all of
these chemicals we are literally drawing
the body's life force and turning it
into chemistry and so for the short term
that's cool
but the arousal that's created from
those stress hormones
is a rush of energy
and so then people use the problems
and the conditions in their life to
reaffirm their conditioning or their
addiction to that emotion
and in a sense they become addicted to
the life they don't even like
and this is why change is so hard
so then when a person makes up their
mind to change and they say okay i'm not
going to say i can't i'm not going to
judge another person i'm not going to
blame i'm not going to complain i'm not
going to make excuses i'm not going to
be a victim i'm not going to talk trash
about anybody i'm just going to stop
well that works out really well for the
first couple hours
when the bodies sing you're out of
schedule you normally at eight in the
morning you get in traffic and you're
angry then at 11 o'clock you check your
emails and you're really judgmental and
frustrated the body's saying well you've
been doing this for the last 20 years
you're just going to stop today so now
the body which has been conditioned
emotionally to be the mind wants to
return back to its familiar territory to
the known
so the body starts influencing the mind
and it says you know come on
this is a good time to judge that come
on this is a good time to suffer it's
your ex's fault it's it's your it's the
government's fault it's uh
you know it's the weather what the news
whatever it is and if we
accept
believe and surrender to that thought
without analyzing it it slips by and it
begins to program the autonomic nervous
system to make those pharmacy of
chemicals
and so
that's when the person makes the same
choice
does the same thing
creates the same experience just for
that familiar feeling
okay i'll complain just so i can feel
suffering then
they'd rather
be unhappy
and step into the unknown well look i
mean i think that emotions are energy in
motion and so let's just say that um
we share the same experiences okay i
don't we're friends and we share the
same experience you're from london i've
been to london my daughter lives in
london and we have hey you do this i do
that you did the you know you own this i
own that you know so what we do is we
actually look to see when we meet people
if we're matching neurologically if
we're matching emotionally so if we
share the same experiences we share the
same emotions and if we share the same
emotions we can relate to one another so
this is where it gets sticky so then the
moment you start saying ah
that person did that to you once yeah
that person i had a similar experience
to that person that to me now
now
we open the door like i'm going to use
you to reaffirm
my
attachment to that emotion
and let's just work it up so that you
can suffer and i can suffer and then we
can have a conversation and literally
we're sharing the same energy and if
we're sharing the same energy we're
sharing the same information and we're
bound by an invisible field
of energy that keeps us connected yes so
then what does it take to break that
energetic field and energy that's
greater than the energy that's holding
it together that's how you separate
atoms that become a molecule you they're
they're bound by an invisible field of
energy that's keeping them connected so
you got to use a greater energy than the
energy that's holding them together to
separate them well in order for you to
change then you can't have energy
without awareness or consciousness
you've got to go to a greater level of
consciousness and change your energy and
nobody changes j until they change their
energy when they change their energy
they change their life so then
you may say well this person you know i
i use this person and i use my enemy to
reaffirm my addiction to hatred i use my
co-worker to reaffirm my addiction to
judgment
i use my ex to reaffirm my
addiction to resentment that we have
these different people in our lives that
we need to remind us of who we think we
are the enemy dies and you find another
one
you know you know your co-worker uh
leaves and you start judging another one
it's just
it's not any it's not that so then
when there's no longer a vibrational
match
when you start doing the work
there's no longer a vibrational match
with you and your past present reality
that that person or that condition any
longer
that person or condition is going to
spiral away because you're no longer
you're no longer in need of that so then
our life begins to change when we change
our energy and we begin to take our
power back that's essential for us to
begin to create with now some people
can't handle that because
they're not conscious that they're doing
it so they'll be working on their vision
of the future
and yet they'll spend two hours
lowering their energy back into
victimization or suffering and they want
to know why their future isn't happening
well there's an unconscious program
let's go after that and once you start
going after that
now all of a sudden your life starts to
change again so you can't say it doesn't
work
on some level we don't work and if
you're really invested in this
the question is what is it about me
where am i directing my attention or my
energy who am i using to reaffirm some
conditioning that i need to remember as
my old self so then when you stop
reacting to the person or the person is
now complaining to you and you're not
complaining back
it's going to be an uncomfortable moment
because
you're all of a sudden seeing a part of
you
you used to be that you no longer are
and you have to be willing to not go
there and over time that person will
thank you and they'll say i didn't even
know that i was complaining that much
and
by changing yourself you help
unconscious
and not go unconscious and it turns out
that 95 of the time we're unconscious so
if you're going to stay conscious then
there's an element that also requires a
certain amount of awareness or energy
and you got to step outside of that
unconscious state so the thoughts that
they're thinking
are slipping by their awareness
unnoticed because they're hardwired in
their brain because they've been saying
i can't it's too hard my life will never
change it's someone else's fault those
thoughts have consequences in the body
so then if a person then becomes
conscious
of those unconscious thoughts becomes
aware of how they speak and how they act
and they notice
how they're feeling they're no longer
the program they're the consciousness
outside the program and that's the first
step to change so
there are
when you when you're distracted by your
environment and you got your cell phone
and your tweeting and your
instagramming and facebook and whatever
people do you're distracted by that
feeling
but i now know that if you take a person
and you say okay close your eyes
sit in the in the silence of any
external stimulation remove the
environment sit your body down like an
animal body is the animal tell it to
stay i'm gonna feed you
you can check your cell phone you can
shower you can have your coffee but when
i say
and so then here comes the challenge
right so and and then if you say then
you're not going to live in the familiar
future familiar past or predictable
future you're not going to think about
how long you've been meditating what you
got to do you you labor
uh for that present moment
people think when they do this that
they're doing something wrong because
there's such discomfort that comes with
it
but they're in the unknown they're
actually doing it right people say i
think i'm meditating wrong i always say
oh no no no you're doing it right
because when you notice that your body
wants to get up and
check your cell phone or have a cup of
coffee and you become aware that it's on
autopilot and wants to do that and you
say
come on over here
and you return it back to the present
moment
you're executing a will now that's
greater than the program and if the
person
wants to just get angry while they're
sitting there there's an arousal and
they notice the body is amping up and
revving up and they settle it back down
now they're telling the body it's no
longer the mind
that they're the mind now we've
researched this
and it's tedious
in the beginning at first because david
is fighting goliath
but if you keep practicing it just like
training an animal
sooner or later the body acquiesces
sooner or later the body is trained to a
new mind and when that happens
there's a liberation of energy the body
goes from particle to wave from matter
to energy and there goes that emotion
literally liberated from body as energy
so the person who has the strong emotion
to some circumstance in their life
and they're
working and lowering the volume of that
emotion the more they lower the volume
of that emotion the more they're going
to take their attention off that person
and problem and they're going to take
their power back there's going to be a
break in their attention from that
circumstance and now they build their
own field and now there's energy to heal
now there's energy to create a new life
now there's energy for the mystical
moment because they've overcome their
old personality self so
i think you know it's not like thinking
positively that's not the message it's
it's overcoming
overcoming
overcoming overcoming until we become
somebody else and when that occurs and
the person starts thinking differently
and they start acting differently
and they start feeling differently
they're a new personality and yeah they
they start seeing those synchronicities
and serendipities
how
bad
does it have to get i mean to what
denominator
to what lowest level do you have to
reach
before people really make up their mind
to change my message is why wait i mean
when you're feeling so altered
emotionally you feel so bad that's the
moment you could actually see yourself
for the first time because you're you're
not answering your cell phone you're not
responding to all your texts you're not
watching tv you're not going out to
dinners you're not calling people back
you're something's altered in you and
you're starting to become self-aware
right
so then
people wait to that lowest moment where
they can start to see themselves through
the eyes of somebody else well if you're
waking up every day and you're combining
a clear intention with an elevated
emotion and you're changing your
emotional state to be
elevated
you could still see the old self from an
elevated point of view and be state
conscious then from a limited point of
view and that's what i want for people
like let's go i mean what do you got to
lose what people are going to start
wondering like did you change your
medication what's up with that guy
something's different about him you're
not predictable any longer right then we
say to our
our community you know when you're
changing you just stop talking about it
you're just too busy being it
something's happening you know and
that's
the repetition of getting a few days in
a row
of that really well i always say
god if you had a great meditation you
wake up feeling better
at the end of that meditation than when
you started and you do that the next day
and then the next day you're gonna start
feeling better all the time and that
your body's gonna start feeling better
and everything's gonna start feeling
better and you're gonna start feeling
better about life so
you ask the person why are you so
unhappy why are you so frustrated why
are you so resentful the moment you ask
that their brain is going to associate
that emotion to a past event through a
memory into a memory
that's because they have nothing to look
forward to in their future so if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future
it just means to me that you're more in
love with your past
than you are with the future so how do
you teach people to believe in a future
that they can't see or experience with
their senses yet but they've thought
about enough times in their mind that
their brain is literally changed to look
like the event has already occurred the
latest research in neuroscience says
that's absolutely possible we know that
and how do you teach a person
to select a new possibility in their
future and begin to emotionally embrace
that future before it's made manifest to
such a degree that their body as their
unconscious mind is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment and they're signaling new
genes in new ways ahead of the
environment
now to their body begins to change to
look like the event has already occurred
we've proven that that's possible now
think about this so the more you think
about your desired future the joy
the gratitude the
uh
the feelings you want to have that are
more positive the more you think about
it as it's as a future thing happening
the more your body shifts now
exactly so your body is believing it's
living in that future reality in the
present moment now think about this the
stronger the emotion you feel from some
condition in your life the more altered
you feel inside of you the more you
narrow your focus on the cause and the
brain freezes an image and takes a
snapshot and that memory now is embossed
in the brain it's branded in there so
then people think neurologically within
the circuits of those past experiences
and they feel chemically within the
boundaries of those emotions and the
stronger the betrayal the stronger the
trauma
the more the body's living in the past
right so then so how you reverse that so
now
if you truly got passionate about a
future we've all done this you get a
wild idea in your mind and you start
holding on to that vision and you're
preoccupied with it all of a sudden the
thought in your mind becomes the
experience and you start feeling the
energy of the future now the stronger
the emotion you feel from that vision
the more you're going to pay attention
to the picture in your mind and now
you're remembering your future and vice
versa the stronger you pay attention to
the feeling of the past pain you're
going to create the pain in this moment
exactly so then so it requires a
coherent brain
and we now know that there's a formula
for that and we've got beautiful
research to show that people can do it
they just have to practice and it
requires a coherent heart because
resentment frustration in patience
creates a very incoherent heart yeah and
when that heart becomes incoherent you
stop trusting yourself there's no energy
you stop trusting in your future
so then if there's physical evidence in
your brain and body
physical evidence to look like the event
has already occurred
it's quite possible you'll be thinking
neurologically within the circuits of
your future and you begin to feel
chemically within the boundaries of that
emotion of your future and how you think
and how you feel is your state of being
and now your state of being is living in
the future instead of the past now
the moment you disconnect from the
emotion of your future because traffic
or some co-worker or your ex or whatever
people come up with
now you're back to the energy of your
past and now you're going to start
looking for it analyzing why hasn't it
happened well if you're feeling the
emotion of your future why would you
look for it because you would feel like
it already happened and that is the
place where the magic happens so then
you can't just do this get up and then
return back to your old state of being
you got to maintain that modified
statement
when life happens small let me finish
with a face right now how do you
maintain well of course of course i mean
we all take blows in our lives yeah and
and we all react emotionally but the
question is
how long are you going to read right so
then if you can't mediate and regulate
your emotional reactions and those
emotions linger for days that's
for some people mood and then months
temperament
years personality trait so then the
person's personality is literally based
on the past but they don't know that
because they're doing it over and over
again it becomes a subconscious program
so now
if it requires a coherent brain and a
coherent heart then we have to train
people how to self-regulate what kind of
attention and intention
do you want to place so that that
becomes the loudest voice in your head
and if you keep practicing it the
hardware becomes a software program and
it'll say jay you can do anything jay
you live in no time and accomplish
everything jay
you're unlimited you just got to hang
with it on the other side of this is
greatness whatever you want to program
in there you get the program in there if
you sat down and say how am i going to
be with my wife my husband my partner
how am i going to be with my kids i'm
going to be at work with my co-workers
how am i going to be in traffic
and you close your eyes and you begin to
rehearse in your mind if you're truly
present the brain does not know the
difference between the real life
experience and what you're imagining so
now the brain goes from a record of the
past to a map to the future now you're
installing the hardware keep practicing
it it becomes automatic comes easier now
it's a software program you may just
start behaving differently in order for
you to to really begin to explore the
unknown aspect of yourself you got to
learn how to get beyond the known aspect
of yourself and if you keep coming back
to the known you're going to miss out on
the unknown so you would say well i
don't know anything in the unknown of
course it's the unknown and if you try
to control it there you're back to the
known if you try to predict it you're
back to the known so you got to go
through this trial and error of just
kind of refining your attention refining
your ability and and it's just got to be
something like playing tennis or playing
golf or doing martial arts or working
out or crocheting or dancing the salsa
you just got to keep going man in the
beginning it's tedious and then when you
start finding your groove like our our
community
they don't miss their morning
meditations yeah you know why because
the magic is happening and they know if
they miss it they're gonna they're gonna
cut off from the magic so they whether
they're tired whether they're hungover
whether they're what they're right
they're in right you know and if you if
you wake up in the morning
and you can't get your butt out of bed
you know what that means it just means
you can predict the feeling of
everything that's going to happen in
your life your body's resigned
so then so then you know when you went
on a school trip when you were a kid you
know you woke up before your parents
yeah you knew something new is going to
happen that's the body going wake up
wake up it's something unexpected is
going to happen what happened to us
christmas day
so why not
you know put in your put in your time
and then and then measure the effects of
you would cause i mean become a
scientist in your life and really start
to experiment with it okay let me change
my energy let me just write down four
thoughts
that like i can it's too hard i'll start
tomorrow this doesn't feel right
whatever it is it's be this person's
fault just write those down and say
these thoughts like gandalf on the
bridge yes you may not pass today this
is the end yes so then if you become
conscious of those thoughts now you're
the governor of your thoughts what what
what actions what behaviors do you want
to change do you complain you blame
you judge do you make excuses how do you
talk do you speak limited just pick four
things
that you're not going to do any longer
yeah
what emotions get you in trouble what
are the emotions that you're addicted to
too right that you're addicted to that
keep you returning back to your past if
you don't know
close your eyes for about 30 minutes and
just watch where your mind goes and
watch your feelings and just say okay
it's frustration it's unworthiness it's
self-doubt it's guilt it's frustration
it's shame
just
become conscious of those and just
review them in your mind so that you
don't go unconscious them in your waking
day we have a thousand reasons i have
more than a thousand reasons every day
to be unhappy with managing companies
and staff and people all that but but
then when you rise above that
and you choose just who you want to be
i think it makes a big impression
uh on your on your family first yourself
and your family and your friends and the
people you work with and then finally
our communities so
i think that people are starting to
figure that out there and and when they
imagine oxytocin levels in our student
body
the love hormone the love chemical 200
times outside of normal the latest
research on oxytocin is slight slight
elevation in oxytocin it's impossible to
hold a grudge now so then
what that means is you feel
so amazing
that why would you want to
hold a grudge against that person so
forgiveness then is not something that
you have to try to do to be spiritual
it's the side effect of saying i don't
want to give up this feeling for you or
anybody so i'm letting it go i'm freeing
you i'm freeing myself and my goodness
there's more liberation of energy
i call that the natural state of being
and we're knocking on that door why
because as you begin to open your heart
to life again and you start trusting in
your future and trusting in yourself a
little bit more and you start
self-regulating with your heart
you do that properly and you lead from
that place from that level of awareness
your life will change
in dramatic ways and why is that
essential
because when people start doing that
effectively
oxytocin signals nitric oxide nitric
oxide signals a chemical called
endothelial derived relaxing factor and
that causes the arteries in your heart
and lungs jay to literally swell just
like when you're
when your sexual organs are aroused and
blood flow moves into them male and
female that's a different consciousness
there's a different energy in there
imagine the same intensity moving into
your heart
that's what people are experiencing that
is a level of love
it's not like a love for your puppy it's
not like the love for your partner this
is transcendent of that this is the most
familiar unfamiliar feeling you will
ever have it'll be distant and at the
same time very close and you'll start to
see the hidden meaning behind all things
and now
when you walk
in the presence of your greatest
betrayer
the person who threw you under the bus
whatever it is when you walk in from
this place
there will be no emotional reaction you
will just see that person for who they
are who you used to be now compassion
then is no longer something that you
have to try to do it's the end product
of doing the work and i think that
mystics and saints and
masters of old understood this
so when they thought of that person
they didn't allow that thought to
produce a feeling or an energy that
would lower their energy
they understood that when they had the
thought of that person they saw their
limitation it wasn't hurting them it was
only hurting themselves now
i think that if the world was doing that
wow we'd have a very different world
thoughts uh to me produce an electrical
charge in the quantum field
and feelings produce a magnetic charge
in the quantum field
thoughts wait thoughts produce a what an
electrical charge okay and feelings
produce a magnetic charge and how you
think and how you feel
broadcast an electromagnetic signature
that influences every single atom in
your life the thought sends the signal
out now think about this and the feeling
draws the event back so you could have
the intent that you want wealth you want
health you want success that's your
intent that's your thought but if you're
waiting for the experience to happen to
feel it then you're not
drawing the experience to you because
you're not feeling the emotion right so
then
teaching people once again how to
balance their thoughts and feelings
because you can you can enter that cycle
either place sometimes we do a
meditation
we start opening our heart we start
elevating the body's energy and then
those emotions can drive certain
thoughts of your future other times you
open your awareness you create brain
coherence you have the vision of your
future you begin to emotionally
experience it however you want to jump
on that cycle
and then sustain it because the longer
you're conscious of that energy
the more you're drawing your future to
you so then most people spend their
lives right
they we live in this realm called space
time three-dimensional reality and you
move your body through space in
three-dimensional reality it takes time
yeah so everything all your goals all
your dreams all your visions you're
going to have to get your body up and
drag it through space every day to pay
off that you know that home that's in
your future right right
when you create from the field instead
of from matter
when you use a vibrational match between
your energy and some potential and your
thoughts and feelings are coherent now
you are going to begin to collapse time
and space where the experience is going
to be drawn to you now now you're the
vortex to your destiny and now you don't
have to go anywhere to get it because
you're not playing by the rules of
three-dimensional reality you're playing
by the rules of energy and the quantum
if the word meditation means become
familiar with right
then you know people say oh well you
shouldn't focus on the negative well
really that's 95 of who you are and you
got to begin to dismantle or denature
that old personality and that means
you're going to have to come up against
the cravings that the body has
emotionally you know like it is it's
eight o'clock in the morning and you're
doing your meditation you're normally in
traffic and you want to get angry and
your body's going hey you're off
schedule so let me just find something
that's mapped in the brain that i i'll
bring up a past experience why you can
feel a little anger well once you become
aware of that
now
now the game is on right yes because now
you're working to become conscious of
that and not go unconscious again and it
takes an incredible amount of awareness
yes it takes a great amount of
consciousness and you can't have
consciousness without energy so you got
to raise your energy in order to get to
otherwise you're going to be consumed
yes you're going to return back right so
gosh so if you start becoming familiar
so conscious of those unconscious
thoughts they would never slip by your
mind unchecked by you now
that is when you really catch yourself
right and the research shows that you
can get better at this you could
actually sense the thought before it
comes so then you start firing and
wiring new thoughts you start thinking
to yourself who am i going to be when i
open my eyes well how am i going to how
am i going to make a difference in the
world today who am i going to be
how am i going to love how am i going to
give how am i going to serve how am i
going to contribute what what things do
i want to really do today and the in the
act of closing your eyes and just
thinking about and rehearsing what
you're going to do
your brain doesn't know the difference
and if you get caught up in it
you begin to install the neurological
hardware in your brain to look like
you've already done it now the brain's
no longer a record of the past now it's
a map to the future you are priming your
brain and if you keep doing it yes the
hardware will become a software program
you know what that means you just might
start acting like a happy person well
there's no surprise there you install
the circuits stress hormones arouse the
body so you have your attention on your
body stress hormones alert the brain so
you're aware of everything in your
environment like an octopus with
tentacles in all different directions
you got to control and predict
everything in your life
and if you're living by the hormones of
stress you're always investing your
attention and energy into the known
future based on the past so you're on
you're on a you're in a line of time
here in a timeline so then let's think
about it
how you gonna make thought more real
than anything else are you gonna create
from thought well let's close our eyes
let's disconnect from the environment
right less sensory information coming
into the brain less distraction as you
said let's play some soft music in the
background let's stick some ear plugs in
our whatever you want to do diminish
sensory way now you're sitting down
you're not eating
you're not tasting you're not smelling
you're not feeling
so there's more less less sensory input
coming into your body so then now your
brain waves begin to change they start
slowing down and you move from this beta
brainwave pattern where you're aware
that you have a body in space and time
or your attention is on the outer world
or your senses are giving you
information less sensory information now
your inner world starts becoming more
real than the outer world and you're not
the voice in your head that's always
talking to you as your brain waves
change you start seeing images and
pictures and symbols unless in that
vocalization that sub-vocalization so
your brain waves start changing the
alpha you're going to start creating
start dreaming pretending right
so then
if you say to your body
you're going to sit down for an hour and
i know you're on a program because you
wake up every morning and do the exact
same thing and now i'm going to make you
sit just like said to an animal you sit
you stay and your body's going to say
i'm going to die my bladder is going to
explode i need a coffee i got a lot of
emails to do that's the program
and you say to your body
today we do battle today this is it and
you sit through that and you make your
way even though your body's trying to
get up and you keep settling it back
down
i'm telling you when you start your day
that day you will be more kind more
loving less judgmental more patient more
present because you're mastering the
present moment that means you're not in
the predictable future you're not in the
familiar past you're mastering time and
so then if where you place your
attention is where you place your energy
and all of your attention is in the
present moment
you've got a lot of energy to do amazing
things and you know when someone's
present with you in your life because
they're paying attention to you yeah and
you know when they're not present
because they're not paying attention to
you so so the act of getting more
present means you're putting a lot of
energy in the present moment and you're
taking your power back from all these
things and people in your life so
we teach people this
as they start breaking through and they
start being able to unfold into this
field as an awareness
and they're not putting their attention
on their boss or their ex or their wife
or their kids or their cell phone or
their whatsapp or their facebook
they're they're they're they're not
thinking at all
so then as they're sensing the space
they can't think and if you can't think
you can't analyze and if you can't
analyze
the analytical mind is what separates
the conscious mind from the subconscious
you just open the door wow and so now
wow you can reprogram and if you could
give everyone in the world
an experiment to do for 30 days or one
activity that they'd have to do every
day for 30 days what would it be oh i
would ask them to take out a piece of
paper and write down every thought
that they've been thinking that's
standing in the way between their future
and and where they are
to write down every habit or behavior
even how they speak that stops them from
becoming the person that is healthy
wealthy or free and then to begin to
recognize the emotions
that keep them in the same state of
being every single day and become so
conscious of those thoughts behaviors
and emotions that they wouldn't let any
of them slip by unnoticed by them then i
would have them write down the thoughts
they do on a fire and wire in their
brain i would have them write down what
the behaviors look like of a great
person that they wanted to become
and i would have them practice thinking
about it and practice rehearsing it and
then i would say to them
what emotions would you feel when your
future happened because you have to
teach your body emotionally what that
future feels like before it happens and
every day if you practice that
diligently and sincerely and just become
conscious of who you no longer want to
be and keep becoming conscious of who
you do want to be
you should begin to see evidence in your
life and when it comes in a way that you
least expect
that surprises you and leaves no doubt
that it's come from a greater mind then
you'll be inspired to do it again and
now we believe we're more of the
creators of our lives if you said well
listen i'm not going to wait for my
healing
to feel gratitude i'm not going to wait
for my new relationship to feel love
i'm going to actually teach my body
emotionally
what that future feels like before it
happens now
this is a big turnaround for a lot of
people because we're so reliant on the
outer world to change our inner world
right waiting and perspiring and waiting
is not creating i mean period and when
people are they could have the greatest
intentions in the world
but if they don't combine that with an
elevated emotion there's no signal
because the elevated emotion is the
carrier it's the energy that carries the
thought
so then
when we're in separation in lack waiting
for our wealth to feel abundance we're
basically living our whole life in pain
right
so then if you reason this and a person
can get up from their meditation and
they literally feel differently
and they're feeling the emotions of
their future before it happens this is
turning
the whole process around
they can't be looking for why would they
be looking for it if they felt like it
there it already happened now there's no
separation now this is
when those serendipities and
coincidences and opportunities begin to
show up in people's lives so it's work
but then when they start seeing the
experience in their life
all of a sudden they
start believing they're more of the
creator of their life yeah and less of a
victim of their life a community of
like-minded like like ant similar energy
of people
uh everybody understands they get one
another you know you you communities
tends to be the thing now that in terms
of our
social media and the feedback we're
getting everybody wants more community
because you get a you get a thousand
people an audience and their energy is
synchronized now you're looking at
something so much bigger we're just
gonna measure this i just talked to a
researcher yesterday we're going to
measure
a thousand people when they reach that
synchronized moment when they're we can
we know that the entire
social coherence in the room is orderly
then if you're
producing a ambient coherent magnetic
field in your heart and you're tuning
into a thought or an intent and you've
got a thousand people doing that and
your energy is going to start
interfering and co-mingling with the
person's next to you when that energy
starts to synchronize
it's going to produce a bigger wave the
higher the amplitude the higher the wave
the more energy there is so now you have
one mind and one heart and now when it
comes to healing others and we've done
the research on this now and we're
collecting the data that we're teaching
people how to administer
a change in energy in the person that's
laying there because it's not matter
that emits a field that's the wrong way
to think about it it's the field that
creates matter
you change the field you change matter
you're not it's not your job to change
the tumor the tumor is the illusion it's
the pattern in the field
that's that that has to be changed so
once people start reversing this then
you start seeing tumors disappearing you
start seeing blind people seeing deaf
people hearing you start seeing people
with parkinson's disease switch on i
mean you start seeing
stage four cancers reversing because now
they're you're you're you're swimming
upstream you're going to the headwaters
and making that change it's so important
then that of the infinite places you can
put your attention
let's put it on your heart
now where you place your attention is
where you place your energy why because
we want this center to bloom
1400 1300 different chemicals that we
storm regenerate the body let's breathe
let's open this up let's practice this
let's start learning how to lead with a
heart a different consciousness yeah in
the beginning
it's a little difficult but
you stay with it and you practice it
pedal by pedal by pedal placing your
attention there you're putting your own
life force back into your heart you're
turning your love inward and the body
will start responding and in a week's
time if we're doing that three times a
day or over and over again
sooner or later that thing is going to
start blooming and just like when your
sexual organs are aroused and they're
engorged with blood
this center
when you start feeling love you make a
chemical called oxytocin
oxytocin signals nitric oxide
nitric oxide
signals a chemical called derived
endothelial relaxing factor you know
what that is
it causes the arteries in your heart to
literally open up so your heart is going
to be filled with blood and oxygen and
nutrients it's physiological it's going
to feel full
you're going to have a heart on in a
sense your heart is going to fail right
and when that happens
you experience a level of love
that passes all understanding you your
cup runneth over i mean it is
and people are in they're sobbing
because
they realize that this this center
finally like a child i think we're all
faced with great opportunities
brilliantly disguised as impossible
situations
and in order like for me personally and
i and after looking through your book
and reading a good portion of it i mean
for me there's there's no school
of ancient wisdom that you need to go to
to be initiated your life is your
initiation if you're paying attention so
we meet challenges in our life from a
certain level of mind right a certain
level of consciousness or
unconsciousness and even einstein said
we have to go to a greater level of
consciousness
than the consciousness that's created
the problem what is consciousness
consciousness is awareness and awareness
means possibilities that you haven't
thought of before
so
we could we confront problems or
challenges in our life and as a side
note
i was having breakfast with a researcher
just last week who's studying what
happens when we perceive a condition in
our environment as a problem how it
weakens the organism they're measuring
this and when a person sees it as a
challenge how they draw energy they
raise the energy of their body back into
order
so
if we said i want to be
wealthy or i want to be healthy
well what you want to be that because
you're not it
so the initiation of going from not it
here to it here you're gonna have to
climb some steps and there's going to be
some blind spots so you try it out and
it doesn't work
well that's because there's a part of
you that's still in a habit there's part
of you that's still unconscious okay so
what is it about myself and that
circumstance
that i am feeling
about that circumstance and that feeling
is causing me to think about it so you
say oh it's impossible they'll never
change i'll hire a hitman i'll hire the
mafia i'll hire an attorney i'll have my
friend's friend to talk to him and
nothing changes right well
you're not you're not separate
from that experience you're involved in
it and how you think and how you feel
broadcasts energy into the field so your
energy is the same every day and as long
as your energy is the same nothing's
going to change in your life either and
nobody changes until they change their
energy so then
what piece of knowledge
what piece of information what would
love do what would greatness look like
okay i don't know
all right well certainly somebody in
history has faced this problem
don't get on facebook and say does
anybody have any answers don't get
go look it up and study and read and
learn you'll own it and you'll say wow
that person that was wealthy
they failed 500 times
well hell i had the wrong view of wealth
okay then failure's not a thing i got to
overcome failure well yep just climbed a
step yeah okay i'm reacting to that
circumstance with the same emotion that
emotion is firing the same thoughts i'm
broadcasting the same energy into the
field
if i were facing that circumstance and
situation again with that person that
circumstance what do i learn from that
circumstance how could i do it
differently the next time
find out a solution and rehearse it
install the circuitry so when you get in
the circumstance you're not going to
respond in an automatic habituation yeah
now you're at a greater level of
consciousness now you're looking at
possibilities that you weren't looking
at before because you were unconscious
now
that process of trial and error is so
important in the spiritual path
how many times
do we have to forget before we remember
and then we remember and we forget again
and it takes constantly remembering
until we stop forgetting and when we get
to that point now we're conscious
now there's wisdom and wisdom is the
memory
of the experience without the emotional
charge now you're ready for the new
adventure so then
people draw conclusions and say oh it's
that person that ripped me off as that
person that
what now now you don't create your
reality you only create reality when
things are good
well somehow you got to tango through
this somehow your objectivity in not
reacting emotionally
is going to change the energy of how you
address this situation consciousness is
awareness awareness is paying attention
and noticing and so 95
of who we are by the time we're 35 years
old is a set of unconscious automatic
programs that we've just practiced so
many times that we're not consciously
thinking about those so in order for you
to change to answer the initial question
that you asked
the first step is you got to become
conscious of your unconscious thoughts
and you gotta you gotta start looking at
those hardwired thoughts that that you
think every day that are just circuits
that have been fired and wired together
how do we do that should we write a list
at the end of the day or one of the most
common thoughts we had that day like how
does someone become aware you don't have
to do that you just have to sit down
close your eyes and not move and then
you'll get you'll you'll start seeing
what am i thinking about right now yeah
and all you want to do is observe the
thought because
when you begin to observe that thought
you're no longer the program now you're
the consciousness observing the program
and you're starting to pull out of the
program but thinking about the thinking
yeah who's doing the thinking of the
thinking
about the thinking that's who you are
when you're not the program that's
awareness right you got to become aware
of how you speak how you act become so
conscious
so aware of it that you won't go
unconscious and let that thought or that
behavior run you you got to say oh my
god
this feeling that i've been living by
for the last 20 years
is actually guilt i didn't know it was
guilt because it just feels like me
and all of a sudden as you start
becoming conscious of it you're
beginning to objectify your subjective
self you're you're pulling out of those
programs and nobody likes to do that
because it's uncomfortable they'd rather
turn on their cell phone start texting
get on the internet
you know watch tv to distract them from
that moment and that is what they have
to move through in order to get to their
to their own personal freedom so the
first step is becoming conscious and
meditation means to become familiar with
to become conscious of to to become so
conscious
of your unconscious self that you won't
go unconscious to any thought any
behavior or emotion and get ready
because it takes a tremendous amount of
energy
to do that and awareness
to stay conscious and so
we fall from grace yeah fine you gotta
you got you're awake you got another day
let's go again how often do you fall oh
my gosh i mean
how many times have i done it thousands
but i'm not gonna give up because
the moments
in which i do connect or the moments
that i do have that transcendental
experience
what matters the most after it when i
have that transcendental moment i look
back
at all of those difficult meditations
those difficult days and those are the
ones you remember you don't remember the
good meditations you remember the ones
where you came up against yourself and
you went a little further and you said
i'm gonna go a little further and go a
little further
or
you had a rough day and you just went in
and you just you at the end of the day
you surrender and you have the classic
oh my god moment
there's no linear correlation it's just
whether you're willing to live in
creation instead of living in survival
and so
you get better at it you know we just
get better at it and for me
staying conscious and staying aware and
staying present
is an art because
you you know when someone's present with
you in your life because they're paying
attention to you
you know when they're not present with
you because they're not paying attention
to you so imagine this field of
information this
this this intelligence that lives within
you and i that's governing everything
material in this world it's a
self-organizing intelligence
you have access to it so you better get
present with it
as well as you can get present with
anything else and just because you can't
see it
doesn't mean it doesn't exist
that that that realm you can't
experience with your senses you can only
experience with your awareness
so then
people have to take their attention off
their bodies and go from a somebody to a
nobody
take their attention off the people in
their life and go from that they
identify with and go from a someone to a
no one take their attention off the
things in their life their cell phone
their computer their car and go from
something to nothing take their
attention off where they sleep where
they work where they're sitting and go
from somewhere to nowhere take their
attention off the predictable future in
the familiar past and time and go from
some time to no time and now if you're
taking all of your attention off of
everything material in this
three-dimensional reality now there's
only one other thing that's left that
means you're an awareness your
consciousness and now
that is the bridge that is the door to
the quantum field and you can't enter
the quantum field as a somebody
so
if someone has spent their whole life
working on having the perfect body or so
much so they have so much attention on
their pain
where you place your attention is where
you place your energy it's going to take
some work for them to take all of their
attention off their body right because
they'll go they'll do it and then
they'll go back let's see if the pain's
still there oh the pain is still there
so
it's a little bit of a waltz in the
beginning but as people start applying
this
you start getting better at it let's
demystify meditation because it has so
many stigmas around it close your eyes
retreat from your life
disconnect from your body disconnect
from your environment disconnect from
your schedule and just give yourself an
hour or 45 minutes or 20 minutes because
when you invest in yourself
you invest in your future and when you
believe in yourself
you believe in possibilities and when
you believe in possibilities you believe
in yourself and if you don't believe in
possibilities then you don't believe in
yourself and you don't believe in
yourself you don't believe in
possibilities so then but if you have a
community a living organism yeah where
it's becoming the new normal yes and you
want to join that living organism and
you want to you want to be a part of
that and and every every stride you make
feeds the living organism every stride
every effort you make
to connect is is amazing because
that which we are seeking is seeking us
it's not like
it is it matches our efforts and so then
when when people have that
uncompromising will
the same way that they go shopping for a
dress or a pair of earrings or go to the
gym and work out with the same intensity
with the same passion
come up against themselves and just say
when the body's going given everything
it has it's when you say that's all you
got that's it that's all you're going to
put out to work i'm ready yeah and so
then
when you start overcoming that
the side effect of it is that all of a
sudden you're happy for no reason
and you're less seduced in believing
that something else you need something
outside of that outside of you to make
you feel better all of a sudden you're
feeling better every day without
anything outside of you
and now all of a sudden you start
showing up unpredictable in your life
you're saying that ed guy he's different
he's on a different medication
but in actuality you're just freer right
and so so then as we begin to remove
these layers that stop the flow of the
divine in us that had an essence in us
the side effect is we become more
willful we become more mindful we become
more conscious we become more loving
it's it's it's nature you know it's just
it just it comes becomes who we are at
the end of the day if you really wanted
to be wealthy say
how did i do today did i make the right
choices was i ethical was i purpose
driven was i was i was am i interested
in making a difference was i fair was i
tempered
did i really think before i spoke what
what did i remember reading about that
book about that person that did it how'd
i do
and if you said i when did i fall from
grace when did i lose it okay
i want that opportunity again
i want another shot at that and i'm
going in this way what would love do in
this situation what would greatness do
and now you you evolve your experience
and somehow there's a door there's an
opening something shifts something's
changing and now here we go we climb
another ladder and then all of a sudden
there's another challenge and then
people who finally arrive at their
abundance they could care less if
they're abundant they're already knowing
that they've earned the right for it so
so there's sometimes a shortcut in the
process
if we're if we really learn and we
really get it
but the trial and error is so
important because
not only is the person earning the right
to be wealthy
but they're earning the right to live in
worthiness worthy to receive like hey
you people people come to our work all
the time for a lot of reasons and one of
the common reasons is they want to get
healthy yeah and in their own because
they're dealing with a very serious
health condition and i always say the
same thing to them
stop wanting to be healthy learn the
formula yeah on how to get healthy learn
the formula on how to heal and the
healing will be the side effect of it if
you're obsessing about why am i not
healed you're still the old person you
could become that person every day right
turns out that when you sit down
and the people that we interview that
have had significant changes
when it's no longer about their health
but they are they are out of the
bleachers and they're on the playing
field and they are coming up against the
belief like one lady said god i i always
thought that
this work really worked that this these
concepts are the truth but i never
believed it worked for me
and i was in a car accident in a
wheelchair and then she made the
decision that she was going to overcome
that belief now it was no longer about
her healing it was about overcoming the
belief but she overcame the belief and
showed up every day for herself when you
believe in yourself you believe in
possibilities when you believe in
possibilities you got to believe in
yourself you don't show up for yourself
you don't believe in it yeah and that's
why people don't do the work i mean if
you you believe that your thoughts
created reality
you would show up every day and create
and so a lot of people believe in their
past more than they believe in their
future a lot of people fall in love or
more in love with their past or romance
their past instead of romance their
future or love their future it's it's
that simple so
the initiation process of life is always
going to be there you're always going to
be challenged if if you want to be a
master well then you better learn how to
heal someone else and you're going to
fail a lot of times and if you think
that you're a failure then you'll quit
but if you feel like you just didn't
quite ding it yet and you show up again
to just ding it and you keep evolving
your experience and go deeper how much
more can i open my heart how much more
can i surrender into this infinite field
how much more can i become can i walk is
it with my eyes open people
do meditations and they have great
meditations me included
and then you get up you open your eyes
and you're back in the program and
people want to know why they haven't
healed them we have testimonies of
people
they're speaking the truth they said
my ms
my rheumatoid and my lupus never went
away
i had great meditations i felt better
and then i realized with my eyes open i
was still that person
and now
next level they're in the game catching
themselves or catching how they speak or
watching how they think they're not
letting their body fall in the same
emotional state to put them in the same
past experience that the body's
believing in now this is the this is the
great part and when a person finally
breaks through from the chains
and there's a different consciousness of
freedom that happens
they look back at their past
they want to change one thing in their
past because it brought them to that
present moment that's the path no longer
existing that's the freedom so is it
worth the effort yeah it's no longer
about healing it's no longer about
abundance it's about who you're becoming
i will never work in a relationship i
just won't if i'm working in a
relationship something's wrong i work on
me
i'll bring my best you bring your best
and we get together and we celebrate it
should work it should work and if it
doesn't then i'm going to step back and
see what is it about me not you what is
it about me that i need to really look
at and change now
if there's a vibrational match and it
flows and it's fun and you connect on
physically mentally mind body soul you
know that's cool i i think that's
healthy
uh uh but a permission driven person
can't be in a relationship
where you have to keep going back
and and and trying to fix something i
just i just won't do that i just think
that when it when it's right it's right
and i'll know
yeah yeah
so i think that i do think that uh
relationships uh can be easy
and i i do think i i and i think that
they should be
and i and i think that if you're
heart-centered
uh that's a different place you meet
yeah uh than than uh other emotions and
and
and i and again every time i have a
mystical moment
and i feel that
transcendental love that i don't even
know the word for
uh every time i have one of those
moments i think i got this all wrong
it's just that it it's it is not
chemical it's electric and you got what
all wrong
well the way we view the world the way
we i mean we don't see things how they
are we see things how we are you know
and every inner experience that's
transcendental experience enriches
circuitry in your brain experience
produces
emotion or energy in the body so you
start having transcendental moments
where you start connecting to that field
it's signature it's love i mean but not
love like a love for your puppy
this is like this is like an arousal
this is i don't know the other word but
spiritual arousal yeah and we have the
we have the evidence we can say
oh watch this watch this person's brain
and scientists are studying our work
i'll say oh um watch she's gonna pop in
a few minutes what do you mean just
watch she's going to pop and all of a
sudden this person goes into an arousal
the sympathetic nervous system is so
switched on but the arousal isn't like
an arousal that from the environment
that produces anger or aggression or
fear anxiety or pain or suffering that's
survival in the environment that
produces the arousal this arousal is
coming from energy in the body that's
moving up into the brain and
the arousal is bliss arousal is ecstasy
the arousal is freedom
but it's it's it's not chemical it's
it's you'll feel it in every single cell
in your body now here's the outcome of
that
the outcome of that is that when you
open your eyes
and some conditioning some layer has
been removed
your spectrum of the way the world looks
broadens now because now you're wired to
perceive what's always existed
but you didn't have the circuits in
place to perceive them so then it's the
inner experience that literally trans
transforms our experience of the outer
world and so
when you start having moments where you
hit that kind of frequency or you have
those moments of love
you're less dependent on anyone to bring
you happiness
you're you're okay you can love the
person for the flaws
because you can see a part of yourself
you used to be that you no longer aren't
instead of judgment you have compassion
and you can encourage and and and
communicate from from a level of
connection instead of intimidation or or
competition or however relationships
work the person's doing the vision board
and they're saying when i get my new car
i get my new house i get my new
relationship
then i'm gonna feel so great
now that well then they're back to the
program waiting for it to happen
for them to feel the emotion they're
believing their outer world has to
change in order for them to feel better
there's there's no
effect of drawing the experience to you
with that way
so
the person has to use those tools
to get them into the emotional state
for them to feel like it's already
happened now think about this
if you get up from
a creative process
and you feel grateful
you feel a love for life you feel a joy
for existence
you feel a passion
uh
to
for the moment
uh
you will not be looking for your future
because you'll feel like it's already
happened
it's the moment that we start feeling
those self-limiting emotions that we
feel separation and then we start
looking for it again well then if you're
waiting you're not creating you're
you're in separation again so then yeah
so then
whatever it takes for you to move into a
state of being and what is a state of
being
thoughts are the vocabulary of the brain
feelings are the vocabulary of your body
how you think and how you feel creates
your state of being so then if you wake
up in the morning and you
come come back to your senses with a
clean slate and you say i don't feel
anything you say well let me start
thinking about all the problems in my
life well all those problems are
connected to different people or
different objects of things at different
times and places the moment you remember
your problems a memory is a record of
the past you're thinking in the past
every one of those problems has an
emotion associated with them so all of a
sudden you start feeling unhappy you
start feeling bitter you start feeling
frustrated so now your body's in the
past so then most people then
create a state of being that's connected
to their past and if they're in the
familiar past
then they are going to crave the
predictable future and they're going to
fall back into routine
so then
we want people then to get very clear on
that vision of their future however they
do it and begin to combine that clear
intention with an elevated emotion and
the stronger the emotion they feel
from the vision they're creating the
more altered they feel inside of them
the more they're going to pay attention
to the pictures in their mind and now
they're remembering their future and
biologically it's exactly the same as
remembering your past in fact if you're
not being defined by a vision in the
future it means you're making your past
more real than your future you're
falling in love with your past you're
more in love with your past than you are
with your future that you're believing
in your past more than you're believing
in your future when you get to that
moment
where you have that feeling
that's your compass
because that feeling is going to drive
your behaviors it's going to drive more
of those thoughts and when you feel that
feeling and it's visceral
no person
no thing no experience will stand in the
way between you and that vision and and
you will be initiated in by the universe
into wealth you will be initiated into
health you'll be initiated into freedom
those people all those people that have
healed themselves of all those different
health conditions
they are so humble
and so happy
and they feel so great
that they would never trade this feeling
because of what you thought of them they
they've they've left that program behind
a long time ago they actually don't care
how you think of them they actually are
so happy with themselves
that they are no longer dependent on
anything outside of them now i think
that's a really important moment because
that's the moment we give people
permission in our lives to do the same
right and i think that more and more
people are beginning to figure that out
one of the things about the global
pandemic that i said to my staff and to
my family the moment i heard how the
circumstances in the world changed
i just said i refuse to be a victim
to these circumstances so a victim
consciousness is when
um we allow something in our outer
environment to control the way we feel
and think so i say to you jay why are
you so upset today and you said oh it's
because of this person or circumstance
what you're really saying is something
in my outer environment some person or
some condition is controlling the way i
think and feel and that's not the truth
that's just a response right
so anything that controls our thoughts
and feelings causes us to be victim to
those things and the stronger the
emotion we feel to some circumstance in
our life the more we pay attention to it
and where we place our attention is
where we place our energy so
we're giving our life force we're giving
our power away to that circumstance and
so i just made up my mind that
it was a great opportunity to get into
the cocoon
if you want more top 10 videos they're
not on this channel anymore i have a
dedicated channel just for it go check
it out the link is right there next to
me continue to believe and i'll see you
there